national sandwich month about a week
away never too early though to start
celebrating especially when you have the
list of the best sandwiches in las vegas
that is what al mancini has put together
he's the creator of neon feast a great
app that we can talk about in just a
second but let's talk about this list of
the best sandwiches how did you do it
basically like everything on neon feast
i reached out to people who really know
the local restaurant community so i
surveyed chefs restaurant owners
professional critics people who eat out
all the time and know quality and i gave
him a hundred categories sandwiches
being one of them i said where do you
send your friends and your family when
they want a good sandwich so we came up
with 12. i didn't know if you could
handle 12 today so
yeah we've brought you five okay and
i'll finish all five of them but which
are they ranked in order here or no no
nothing's ranked no particular order
everything on neon feast is just stuff
that is good that comes recommended by
people who know what they're talking all
right let's start over here then okay
we'll start over there this is lardo at
porque it's a porchetta sandwich from
lardo at the cosmopolitan and this is
actually the one import lardo's from
portland it started off as a kind of
food truck mobile thinking guys
oh i didn't bring any napkins i'm sorry
so yeah these are a little messy but um
they set up shop in the cosmopolitan i
know that the chef from portland came in
when they were opening they got it you
know really got everything down making
sure they had all the bread that they
needed and it's really solid it's part
of the block 16 food court that they
have there in cosmopolitan so if you
were there you want to hit larda you do
want to hit it and you do want to ask
for a napkin yes you see how everybody
right after a napkin like everybody's
like nah you want to know you're on your
i use the tablecloth you know okay
what's this one here okay so right there
we have cured and delicious i love cured
and way this is a gourmet shop which is
called mgp specialty foods they're
located over on valley view around post
road they opened this kind of retail
spot where you could not only go in and
shop and buy the same ingredients that
the best restaurants buy but they use
those ingredients to make sandwiches
this is what every chef i know in las
vegas loves this one maybe not every but
most of them love this it's um it is
basically their duck reuben so they use
duck ham hudson valley duck ham and then
they just do a traditional reuben that's
from where that is cured and whey okay
we've got the good witch this is a
downtown classic the dtp the downtown
project runs it these days they're over
in the soho um the soho condos there
right off las vegas boulevard and this
is their cubanette so it's a little bit
like a cuban it has pork butt pork belly
pickle mustard ham swiss and a chicarone
for a little did you get that for a
little bit of the crunch yes that i love
that one i love toasted sandwiches
okay while we're looking at this last
time which i do want to talk about we
have two more but well i know
neonfest.com yes so we don't miss out on
that how can people find you yeah
neonfeast.com you can download the app
from there you can also get it at the
app store either the google play store
or the app store okay next sandwich okay
next up we have vaya focaccio i love
this place it's a little sandwich stand
it's inside ellis island uh ishmaeli
romano just a year ago won the world
sandwich championship at the pizza expo
and everything is on this fresh baked
focaccio bread that he does in-house at
ellis island every day excellent place
take out but it's great places people
said i couldn't do it but i'm going to
get the fish sandwiches okay
here we go bronze cafe
there you
go there you go it going um bronze cafe
they started off in the lgbtq center
right now they're over by desert shores
they like to put a slightly healthy spin
on their sandwiches but as you can tell
they do are willing to go a little bit
overboard with things this is the
complicated order i think they changed
the name on that but it's the turkey
bacon strips bacon jam avocado greens
tomato cucumber basil aioli lemon
vinegar yeah i have to look because you
were memorizing that man you are five
for five there's always there's 12 on
the list you can get the complete list
on neonfeast.com and on the app yes it's
great to have you here max
congratulations on everything else enjoy
the sandwich we'll be right back yeah i
will come on guys